[Musique]
depuis 2015 notre gouvernement a
renforcé les mesures qui protègent nos
institutions contre l'ingérence
étrangère je peux affirmer avec
certitude que c'était toujours une
priorité et qu'on a entrepris des
démarches concrètes à cet égard
[Musique]
devant le comité de la procédure de la
Chambre des communes vendredi un
témoignage attendu mais nous a-t-il
permis d'en apprendre davantage sur les
allégations d'ingérence étrangère dans
le processus électoral canadien voyons
voir ce que pense mes collaborateurs
allaient castonguettes animateurs de
midi info à ici première et chroniqueur
au Toronto Star et au magazine
L'actualité Michel CEG et chroniqueur à
La Presse et Radio-Canada bonjour à vous
trois bonjour bonjour Michel qu'est-ce
qu'on a appris de nouveau du témoignage
de Madame Telford vendredi
la réponse courte Etienne la réponse
longue c'est rien aussi mais on a appris
que elle est sur à peu près toutes les
rencontres sur des questions de sécurité
nationale qui peuvent être faites avec
leur avec le Premier ministre et que
rien n'est jamais caché au Premier
ministre mais vous avez la formule d'une
commission parentale telle qu'elle se
fait un terroir fait que il y a beaucoup
de temps qui est passé par des députés
du parti au pouvoir qui qui jouent en
défensive si on pouvait appeler ça comme
ça ça rapporte un échange très facile et
ça rend pas ça nous permet pas
d'apprendre souvent l'impression que les
députés veulent réussir à placer leur
petite clip à eux dans le discours en
chantant de quelques avais retenu vos
dieux de la performance de madame
qui a un grand mystère qui demeure et un
double mystère le premier pourquoi
est-ce que le gouvernement entendu
existé à ce que madame tellfred avait
passé quelques heures
devant une commission parlementaire
deuxième mystère c'est pourquoi
l'opposition itiné à ce point-là parce
que elle est pas la responsable de
conseiller le Premier ministre sur la
sécurité nationale cette personne-là a
déjà paru certainement que la chef de
cabinet va pas en dire plus sur des
rapports qui touchent la sécurité
nationale que ce que la personne qui est
responsable du dossier se sent autorisé
à partager premièrement deuxièmement
parmi les questions qu'on a entendu par
exemple c'est fait demander je crois par
le NPD neuf voyez-vous pas qu'il est
essentiel maintenant d'avoir une enquête
publique je sais pas moi ce que Madame
talfort croit mais je sais qu'une
employée qu'elle soit chef de cabinet du
premier ministre ou d'un ministre a pas
à donner une réponse là-dessus c'est une
décision politique et d'autre part ce
que j'ai trouvé très très amusant la
personne députée libérale qui préside
n'en finissait plus de féliciter madame
Telford pour la breté de ses réponses
ben oui
bon
effectivement avec qu'est-ce que ça
amène au débats sur le témoignage parce
que ça traîne depuis un bout de temps
les ingérences étrangères votre
processus électorale est-ce que ça
relance quelque chose lundi quand la
période quand les travaux reprennent
dans la chambre des communes
de ce qu'on a entendu je ne pense pas
je me demande moi aussi un peu comme
Chantal pourquoi on a pendant des
semaines insisté pour avoir été le feu
dans le comité pourquoi le gouvernement
a résisté aussi mais pourquoi les
parties d'opposition pensaient qu'ils y
trouvera un
os agrugé parce que j'étais nu en comité
par le mentale sur le la controverse
Witcher souvent avec vous elle avait été
très solide tout comme son collègue
Gérard bottes à l'époque de SNC-Lavalin
on ne devient pas chef de cabinet d'un
Premier ministre d'un pays du G7 par
hasard on est généralement capable de
répondre à des questions notre même si
elles viennent des députés et donc
l'impression qu'on allait apprendre
quelque chose de substantiel ma foi
était peut-être petit peu exagéré du
côté des parties d'opposition oui ça
maintient le sujet dans l'actualité on
en parle aujourd'hui ça va faire
quelques heures est-ce qu'il y a des
révélations qui vont nous permettre
d'aller plus loin autour du témoignage
de qui était le feu j'en doute
sur la marmite ceci dit
non mais il y avait les députés de
l'opposition qui manifestement sont
restés sur leur appétit il y avait aussi
probablement un certain nombre de
journalistes ceux qui ont eu des
informations en primeur qui aurait
certainement aimé ça moi ça avait été
mon cas j'aurais aimé ça que des
éléments de mes reportages soient
confirmés ou infirmer par qui était
Alford pourquoi parce que si elle les
avait démenti j'aurais voulu avoir des
éléments pour la contredire puisqu'elle
les avait confirmés j'aurais été plutôt
fier de mon travail si ça ça donne un
aperçu de ce que Justin Trudeau dirait
devant une commission enquête commission
parlementaire ce sera pas non plus une
très très grande journée la journée une
Premier ministre va se présenter dans un
de ses forums pourquoi justement c'est
pas le premier ministre qu'on a réclamé
à la table de cette commission
parlementaire pourquoi l'élément du
comité ont pas dit on veut entendre ça
de la bouche la bouche de celui qui est
assis dans la Grosse chaise
parce que celui qui est assis dans la
grossesse peut encore plus facilement
que ça chope de cabinet moi sur des
matières de sécurité nationale je ne
parlerai pas
au moins avec la chaîne de cabinet vous
pouvez peut-être avoir et on l'a pas eu
mais vous regardez peut-être plus avoir
des recoupements que vous auriez fait
sur
certaines choses se sont passées etc
mais le Premier ministre vous savez
l'autre chose c'est que on le connaît
maintenant
ces choses là quand tu peux pas répondre
c'est peut-être pas extraordinairement
utile de l'avoir là
alors je sais pas pourquoi il faut pas
demander mais je suis pas sûr que
c'était une quelque chose de stratégique
c'est peut-être parce que la dernière
fois qu'il y a pas eu quelque part il y
a une très bonne journée c'était la
commission
je me dirais bon c'est quoi les chances
qu'il va avoir une mauvaise journée par
rapport à une bonne journée ici c'était
comme un la commission rouleau c'était
presque son meilleur moment de l'automne
alors ça donne pas le goût de le faire
revenir avec un mot là-dessus
peut-être aussi que en faisant venir le
Premier ministre on aura un peu coupé
l'herbe sous le pied de la demande des
parties d'opposition pour une enquête
publique à partir du moment où tout le
monde témoigne en quantité parlementaire
comment on réclame encore une enquête
publique mettons que ça enlève un peu de
souffle dans les voiles de l'opposition
c'est peut-être dit qu'on se
contenterait de la chef de cabinet
l'autre ouais effectivement alors on
verra ce que ça donne demain parce que
ça ça risque de revenir durant la
période des questions toute cette
histoire-là encore une fois l'autre
dossier qui a retenu beaucoup
l'attention c'est lié un peu à ça aussi
cette semaine c'est toute la façon dont
on a géré ce fameux don d'un homme
d'affaires philanthrope chinois lié
selon le globenmil au régime au régime
chinois Pékin la Fondation Trudeau s'est
retrouvée dans la meilleure vous allez
entendre Justin Trudeau cette semaine
qui a défendu la fondation du nom de son
père ça a donné ceci
moi ça fait 10 ans que je n'ai plus
aucune connexion avec la Fondation qui
porte le nom de mon père et je sais
qu'il y a des réflexions et des
questions qui se posent maintenant mais
c'est la Fondation elle-même qui va être
qui doit être chargé de de répondre et
de figurer comment avancer
[Musique]
mardi dernier qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
qu'est-ce qu'on comprend des choses aux
membres
mais je trouve qu'il y a plus de
développement de ce côté-là que du côté
du comité parlementaire qui a entendu
Cathy dans le mesure où
la Fondation Trudeau bon au-delà du
fonctionnement interne visiblement là on
n'a pas toujours fait notre nos devoirs
comme il faut à la fondation au moment
où on se met de l'argent parce que quand
on est rendu à émettre un reçu fiscal au
nom d'une personne ou d'une entreprise
qui n'a pas fait le don et quelqu'un
aurait dû à l'époque flashé que c'était
peut-être pas une super bonne idée donc
au-delà du fait de la manière dont la
fondation Trudeau était gérée quand ça
s'est produit ça nous éclaire sur un
autre volet des tentatives d'influence
des puissances étrangères au Canada on a
la nomination des députés cette façon-là
de travailler on en a entendu parler
est-ce que des candidats qui ont été
appuyés par un donateur ou l'État
chinois etc il y a aussi toute la
question comment on influence de manière
plus large le pouvoir et visiblement les
Chinois avaient l'impression que la
fondation d'un homme qui porte le nom du
premier ministre est un endroit qui
pouvait être intéressant parce qu'aux
États-Unis ça se fait beaucoup les
fondations des des politiciens sont un
endroit d'accès il y a des soupés de
financement des endroits où on peut donc
essayer d'influencer le politique
peut-être les Chinois se sont dit on
peut faire la même chose au Canada voici
essayer et donc c'est une facette
différente de l'influence d'une
politique d'une puissance étrangère au
Canada et ça c'est intéressant
éventuellement c'est une enquête
publique c'est pas tant la Fondation
Trudeau elle-même qui est intéressante
parce que je pense les liens juste un
Trudeau et la Fondation sont assez
minimes depuis qu'il est au pouvoir
c'est la façon dont les puissances
étrangères conçoivent l'influence qu'ils
peuvent avoir et comment ils tentent
d'aller la chercher même si ça
fonctionne pas parce que son en aucune
idée et ça je trouve que c'est
intéressant et éventuellement sur une
enquête publique on devrait étudier cet
aspect là
fondation Trudeau commence à être
difficile à éviter un peu là-dessus
j'ai l'impression que la Fondation
Trudeau va devoir faire des choses plus
complexes et encore plus large que de
faire partie des vignettes une
commission d'enquête éventuellement
parce que dans l'état je vois pas
tellement comment ça peut continuer à
fonctionner moi j'ai été mentor à la
Fondation Trudeau avant que je sois un
Trudeau devienne chef du Parti libéral
les gens que j'ai vu là parmi le conseil
d'administration ou les mentors venez
plusieurs horizons politiques mais pour
la plupart ils avaient en commun d'avoir
une vaste expérience politique soit
comme au fonctionnaire diplômage chef de
partie
je m'étonne que voyant les les dons
afflués au moment où je suis cintre que
d'autres devient premier ministre ça a
semblé à personne un peu étrange qui
soit pas dit on est mieux de s'assurer
que tout est bien réglé bien dans
l'ordre parce que de manifestement on
reçoit pas de la même parce que c'est la
bonne journée de la semaine c'est
quelque chose à voir avec le fait que
quelqu'un qui s'appelle Trudeau est
devenu premier ministre ça je trouve ça
franchement sidérant
un autre aspect de la chose qui
m'intéresse parce que je pense que sur
le côté ingérence dans le processus
sélectoral non c'est plus comme Alex le
décrit de se créer un réseau d'influence
et se mettre du bon côté du Premier
ministre en le flattant dans le bon sens
mais
monsieur Johnston le rapporteur spécial
qui n'était pas au conseil
d'administration de la Fondation au
moment de cette histoire de chèque il
était encore gouverneur général mais qui
a siéger au conseil d'administration par
la suite jusqu'à ce qu'il soit nommé
rapporteur spécial ça le met dans une
position encore plus difficile pour
faire l'économie d'une recommandation
d'enquête publique parce que sa capacité
de vendre cette recommandation là comme
indépendante qui était déjà diminué me
semble réduite presque à néant
ça fait déjà plusieurs fois qu'on dit
les options sont de moins en moins
nombreuses mais là elle s'amenuisent
semaine après semaine Michel est-ce que
la Fondation Trudeau compte tenu du
encore est-ce qu'on peut continuer parce
que il y a quand même du bon qui se fait
dans cette fondation là le travail de
mentorat c'est ça a été presque
unanimandi là est-ce que est-ce que ça
peut continuer comme ça
c'est difficile de repartir sur un autre
nom là alors
il faut à ce moment-là que la fondation
d'une part mettre des règles strictes
sur les les contributions étrangères
vous savez c'est très à la mode dans
beaucoup de pays de dire la diplomatie
peut importante maintenant c'est ce
qu'on appelle la manga le soft power le
pouvoir d'influence c'est clair que je
dois essayer de faire ça alors il faut
il faut il faut qu'il y ait des cloches
qui sonnent à la Convention plutôt qu'à
quelque chose comme ça se passe de toute
évidence c'est pas arrivé ça c'est la
première des choses il faut des règles
il faut des règles de transparence sur
toutes ces choses là qu'il faut pas
oublier que le gouvernement canadien a
donné 125 millions de dollars en
dotation à la Fondation Trudeau alors un
moment donné faudrait aussi voir si
l'argent des contribuables est utilisé à
bon escient ce serait une chose
responsable de savoir mais
cette la saga qui s'est passé avec des
choses un peu ridicules de la statue
depuis un Trudeau à l'Université de
Montréal puis pour que les Chinois
voulaient payer
quelque part il y avait fallu à la
Fondation ça réveille des gens qui
disent et on a peut-être un problème ça
ne s'est pas passé et ça exige
redessiner une
de toutes les
standards de procédure pour que ces
choses-là ne se produit rapidement bon
une chose d'abord la statue rien à voir
avec la Fondation Trudeau entendant nous
ça avait avoir avec l'Université de
Montréal non rien n'avoir
assez de problèmes sans ça
225 millions est intact et il y a
jusqu'à présent aucune suggestion de
malversation financière interne à la
formation tous les deux ce dont il est
question c'est d'avoir accepté un don
douteux sans poser de questions et
d'avoir accepté de faire des ressources
charité à des noms hautes que celui du
donateur ce qui amène la question à
l'eau les amis dans quelle univers
est-ce qu'on accepte de faire ça pour
deux chèques de 70 000 dollars alors que
la Fondation ne dépend pas de dons pour
survivre c'est quand même particulier
comme comme relation à la décharge la
fondation à l'époque on était encore
dans la lune de miel pro Chine de Justin
Trudeau on est en 2015 2016 on n'est pas
vendu aux deux mailles donc c'était dans
l'air du temps et c'est dans l'ADN je
suis parti libéral des nombreuses
affiliés du Parti libéral qui sont à la
Fondation Trudeau cela dit le problème
est plus grave que ce que Michel le
décrit parce que si on vous demandait
demain pour rendre plus communique la
confrontation Trudeau voulez-vous aller
sièges là
[Musique]
et ça ça va être un grave problème le
recrutement le recrutement va être
compliqué effectivement Alex j'entends
Michel c'est tout le temps qu'on avait
malheureusement on se prépare la semaine
prochaine merci beaucoup